so
against
the says from brazil yes nice
c30 the people with g6 is very
interesting here means black what
wants to do but the disadvantage is that i
have no
idea well you can do it i
don't know
okay but well so that the 40 years is
not so dangerous  from
ok
i didn't even pay attention now yes it
is of course not illogical why
not a
whole three he doesn't get any speed either
oh you played stupid yes somehow or
maybe better just took the four
it looks pretty funny here now jak
hour after hour at 5
yes ok that should be fine here
for black
the two good bishops what
a pity
let's do that
now let's just play here
make up a bit of time
yes he can always take a7 i'm
twice if he now and 4 or  that
plays i don't know has could be
a bit awkward with three
against two
i don't know i have anything
specific
to 64
i  then thought b5 springer the four that
can't really be bad
if he plays at 5 on a3 from rohloff
p 2
soja that was probably important
canada with springer b3 here that
maybe exchange
so
especially since you go in here
and you always shoot at him
and now  jumper bab 3 plays
i can also do e5 i think i
at least have to
go today made up a bit of time
yes i think with the active ones a lot of
green is actually okay
doesn't see anything anymore but 83
as well as running with the king
without the  we won't get along in the long run either
I wanted to do five anyway
the innkeeper speaks to david against oh so he
has now in the end running for two years he
has prepared with the king's trains
i didn't really think about it
ok i can do that too  playing
c4 still hangs
after seven because c4 takes c4
okay
so now we have a real
harmony elementary in the game
with the bishop going to the s  pringer and
distributed more
so after empty that should be good for
black the
only problem is that the pawns have
advanced so far from white
played super
you can play that too man I
was allowed yes yes god
stupid
small now but played strangely
so now have  i again a sea
of fans on the day where you play
comedy game here it wo
't be clear later